USUALLY WHAT WAS ALRIGHT GOOD
MORNING WE DON'T HAVE OF A
QUORUM YET BUT ALMOST WAS
STARTED A SUBCOMMITTEE. ON THIS
ASSEMBLY ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AND AND MEDIA
TECHNOLOGY.
COMMITTEE MEETING AND JOB.
SO. LET ME WOULD. I HAVE TO
BILLS TWO PERCENT SO ALL OF.
DO THAT AND I WOULD ASK.
DANTE TO BE.
TO RESIDE HERE.
I'LL BRING THE MAGIC OF OKAY.
THIS IS OUR TARGET AGE BEFORE
BEAUTY.
I OFFER.
HEY GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU.
CHAIRMAN.
HE'D LIKE TO GET STARTED YEAH
I'M GONNA DO THE WHOLE THING
HERE I MIGHT AS WELL. WELCOME TO
THE.
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE
AND.
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR FIRST YOU
WILL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ALL LIKE TWO PERCENT.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ACRES.
ALRIGHT LET GO YES THANK YOU AB
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHTY WILL CLARIFY EXISTING
CHILD LABOR LAW. TO PROVIDE THAT
EMPLOYMENT OF CHILDREN'S IN
ADVERTISING INCLUDES.
DEMONSTRATION OF PROMOTION.
ADVERTISING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND OCCUPATION NONE AS SOCIAL
MEDIA INFLUENCER.
WE ARE WORKING WAS TO LABOR
COMMISSION OFFICE TO ADDRESS ANY
IMPLEMENTATION NEW SHOE.
AND THE MOVE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA MPA A. TO
MAKE SURE THE LANGUAGE JUST NOT
OVER REACH AND TAKING IN
ACTIVITIES OR PERSONS WHICH ARE
NOT INTENDED.
ALL LIKE TO THINK THE STUDIO IN
PARTICULAR. FOR THEIR HELP IN
DRAFTING THIS AL THOUGH
LEGISLATION. AND COMMIT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH WAS TIME.
BOND REFINING THE BILL S. IT
MOVES ALONG. DISTRO HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS SUPPORTED BY.
THIS PARENTS.
WHICH IS A GROUP OF PARENTS WITH
CHILDREN AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY.
WAS THAT I WOULD ASK FOR EUROPE
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU OUT WHILE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU HERE.
KANSEN CHU HERE WALDRON.
ACOSTA HERE ACOSTA HERE DAVID
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HERE MEDINA.
MEDINA HERE IN THIS AREA.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. ON THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
DO YOU HAVE. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. LIKE COME UP.
WELL MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
WERE ACTUALLY NEITHER IN SPORT
NOR OPPOSITION BUT.
SORT OF THAT WILL HELP THEIR
SITUATION HERE.
BUT WE DO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR HAND
TO STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL.
I THINK WE STILL HAVE A FEW
OTHER ISSUES WE NEED TO COVER I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT CONSULTANT
DID AN EXCELLENT JOB OF
OUTLINING. WHAT OUR CONCERN WAS
AND HOW TO LIMIT EXPOSURE FOR
OUR COMPANIES WHEN THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL WHEN IT'S THEY'RE
DEALING WITH THE PARENTS IN THE
PARENTS REALLY NEED TO HAVE THE
CONTROL? SO WOULD CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT I THINK WE'RE
MAKING REALLY GREAT PROGRESS AND
WE APPRECIATE IT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE SO MONARCHS PRESSED HER
SUPPORT JUST COME ON UP.
ANY MEMBERS SIGH HERE FOR ANYONE
HERE PROPOSITION IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
NO.
I TAKE IT THEN.
WE HAVE A.
THEY WANT TO CLOSE MISTER.
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SECTOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE EIGHT
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU.
THAT MOTION IS THE PAST LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT.
KANSEN CHU BY.
KANSEN CHU AYE. WALDRON.
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE.
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE.
AND DO YOU PASS FIVE BUT WE
SHOULD LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS VERY GOOD AND SO THAT
BILLS OUT MISTER CHIU IT MAY
HAVE BEEN ANOTHER BILL THAT YOU
LIKED PRESENT PLEASE PROCEDURES.
ARE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DO
YOU KNOW SOMEONE THIS TWENTY A
HUNDRED.
AND DUH DOES. AB TWENTY THREE.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. WORK
ADDRESS OUR RECOGNITION AND
TREATMENT OF HIT HEAT.
A RELATED ILLNESS TO THEIR FIRST
AID TRAINING HIGH SCHOOL COACH
RECEIVE.
PASSED THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ASSOCIATION'S SAY'S IN
THE COMEDIAN ALICE'S JUST BROUGH
WAS SAFE LIFE.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC HE'D. HE'D
ILLNESS DURING PRACTICE OR
COMPETITION IS THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH AMONG U. S. HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETES.
ALSO HIT IN A HEAT ILLNESS
CAN BE FATAL BUT IS EASILY
PREVENTABLE. AND DEATHS FROM
HEAT ILLNESS CAN BE AVOIDED IF
QUICKLY RECOGNIZE AND
PROBABILITY TREE TREATED.
TO MAKE* TO TRAINING AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THE TRAINING TO BE FULFILLED BY
A FREE ONLINE COURSE THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND IS SO
SUPPORTIVE BY TEACHERS COACHES
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND REGULATORS
AND I ASKED WE ARRIVAL.
VERY GOOD WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LEILANI I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED THANK YOU.
SECOND.
VERY GOOD ANY M. MEMBERS DON'T
WANNA EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
I SEE NONE SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SECRETARY WOULD YOU
KALRA.
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED KANSEN
CHU MOTION TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR KANSEN CHU PINE
KANSEN CHU AYE WALDRON.
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE. DAVID
CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE.
I WE CAN LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS
TO PASS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK RIVER
ELIZALDE AND YOU'D LIKE TO.
TAKE OVER THE
.
HE'S.
SHOP FOR WITH
.
BECAUSE
MR MOMENTS IN THE HOUSE
YOU HAVE A A. B.. THIRTY ONE TEN
TO.
PLEASE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
OKAY.
SURE PLEASE
.
THANK YOU.
THERE.
YEAH I NEVER.
THEN CAME THE.
VERY WIDE AND.
WHICH ESTABLISHES BE ATHLETIC
TRADE PRACTICE.
LICENSES.
AND REGULATIONS PERPETRATORS.
HE ATHLETIC TRAINER LICENSING
COMMITTEE. WITHIN A CALIFORNIA
MORE.
THERE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENT.
NOT REGULARLY FASHION.
GREAT.
ANDERSON WHITE LINES SKILL OF
SKELETAL ISSUES LIKE
DISLOCATIONS AND FRACTURES.
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM A COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY WITH AN ACCREDITED
ATHLETIC TRAINING EDUCATION
PROGRAM.
THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
NATIONAL ATHLETIC TRAINING
CERTIFICATION THROUGH THE BOARD
OF CERTIFICATION.
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF ATHLETIC
TRAINERS HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE.
OR EDUCATION HIGHER THAN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
A RECENT CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
SURVEY OF ATHLETIC DIRECTORS
WITH APPROXIMATELY NINETY
PERCENT RESPONSE RATE.
INDICATES THAT THERE AT LEAST
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY HIGH
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY EMPLOYING AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS PRACTICING AS
AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER WITHOUT
THE APPROPRIATE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING?
THIS MEANS THAT YOUNG ATHLETES
ARE UNKNOWINGLY UNDER THE CARE
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO LACKEY
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TO ACT AS
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LICENSING
BOARD. OR COMMITTEE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S NO ACCURATE.
SYSTEMIC WAY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
REPORT EVIDENCE OF HARM AGAINST
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE THOSE
POSING AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS. AND
HAVE THOSE REPORTS INVESTIGATED
WERE TRACKED.
THERE IS ONLY ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN ALSO PROTECTS
THE EMPLOYERS OF ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AND ATHLETIC TRAINERS
THEMSELVES.
CURRENTLY ATHLETIC TRAINERS
WHO'VE OBTAIN THE PROPER
EDUCATION AND TRAINING PRACTICE
IN A LEGAL GRAY AREA. WHICH
PLACES THEM AT INCREASED RISK OF
LIABILITY.
EMPLOYERS OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS
IN SECTORS SUCH AS EDUCATION.
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
AND INDUSTRIES ARE CONCERNED
THAT THERE IS NO STATE
SANCTIONED SCOPE OF PRACTICE TO
DELINEATE. WHAT ATHLETIC TRADERS
CAN AND CANNOT DO?
IN HEALTH CARE SETTINGS ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ARE OFTEN THE ONLY
PROFESSIONALS THESE EMPLOYERS
HIRE WHO ARE NOT LICENSE.
THIS CREATES A LACK OF CERTAINTY
THAT INCREASES THE EMPLOYERS
RISK OF LIABILITY.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN SOME
SETTINGS ESPECIALLY IN
COLLEGIATE AND PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS AND PERFORMING ARTS. ARE
REQUIRED TO TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE AS PART OF DOING THEIR
JOB.
IN A GROWING NUMBER OF STATES IT
IS ILLEGAL FOR UNREGULATED
ATHLETIC TRAINERS TO PRACTICE
FOR ANY PERIOD OF TIME IN THEIR
STATE.
WHEN AT WHEN CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS TRAVEL OF THOSE STATES
WITH.
THEIR TEAMS ARE THERE COMPANIES
THEY RISK VIOLATING THOSE STATE
LAWS BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
REGULATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY ANYONE CAN ACT AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY EDUCATION
IN ATHLETIC TRAINING. WERE OUR
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MIKE JEWS
ARE THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT I'M
GOING TO START. WITH TERRY
MCCALEB LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON
THE BILL AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN
REGAN ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION.
OF THIS BILL IS LONG OVERDUE
THEIR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL.
AND THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS BILL. AS CALIFORNIA
ATHLETIC TRAINERS WILL BE ABLE
TO TRAVEL TO OTHER STATES.
AND TO A PERFORMED THEIR DUTIES
IN TAKING CARE OF HONORABLE
ATHLETES.
OF THIS BILL HAS BEEN BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE THEY
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR. A YOU REQUESTED AN
AMENDMENT WE TOOK THAT AMENDMENT
AND THAT IS THE BILL THAT IS
PRESENT.
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I IN TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE CONTINUE TO SUPPLY
THEM. A WITH THE NEW MEDIA
STORIES HIGHLIGHTING THE
PROBLEMS THAT TAKE PLACE. WHEN
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE NOT
PRESENT.
AND THOSE WHO SUFFER BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT THERE.
I RECOGNIZE ALSO THAT OVER THE
YEARS THERE'S THE QUESTION OF
SCOPE.
AND WHERE ATHLETIC TRAINERS ARE
GOING TO FIT IN.
OUR WHAT WE DID THIS YEAR THAT
IS DIFFERENT FROM THE PAST IS
THAT WE WENT TO THE TOP OF THE
FOOD CHAIN. AND WE HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND WE SPOKE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION YESTERDAY
AND I BELIEVE THEY HAVE SPOKEN
TO COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM AND WE WORK
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE OPPOSITION
THAT IS HERE TODAY.
THIS BILL IS OVERDUE IT'S TIME
FOR THE ATHLETES PLEASE LET'S
GET IT DONE.
I AM PLEASED INTRODUCED MIKE TO
CZAR. MARCHES ARE IS AN EDUCATOR
AND HE IS A TRAINER. AND HAS
BEEN CLOSELY INVOLVED IN THE
PROMULGATION OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
A GOOD MORNING.
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF STAFF
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT A. B.. THREE ONE ONE
ZERO. AND AS TERRY MENTIONED
THIS IS BILLS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO AB FIFTEEN TEN WHICH
PASS THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
AND WOOD IS TERRY SAID WE
MODIFY.
SOME LANGUAGE AND BY RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM YOUR
COMMITTEE.
WE ALSO LOOKED AT AND RECOMMEND
DACIANS AND SUGGESTIONS
INCORPORATED THOSE FROM THE OTP
WARDEN OTHERS.
AND THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED ATHLETIC TRAINERS
PRACTICING A VARIETY OF SETTINGS
A CALIFORNIA.
FROM CORPORATE INDUSTRIAL
SETTINGS LIKE DISNEYLAND AT
AMAZON.
POLICE AND FIRE DEPARTMENTS
HOSPITALS CLINICS PHYSICIANS
OFFICES.
AND EVEN TRADITIONAL ATHLETIC
TRAINING SETTINGS LIKE
PROFESSIONAL TEAMS COLLEGES.
UNIVERSITIES AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
AND WE HAVE A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL FROM
MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS OF HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER GROUPS.
.
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE'S
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES THE
CIF.
.
AND THEY ALL SHARE A COMMON
VISION OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THESE GROUPS ROLLING BY THE
FACT THAT THE CONTINUED LACK OF
LICENSURE POSE A RISK TO
CONSUMERS ABOUT THEIR TRAINING
SERVICES.
INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF THAT OF YOUNG ATHLETES
UNKNOWINGLY RELIANT UNQUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS.
POSING AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
AND THERE ARE NUMEROUS REPORTS
OF HARM THAT HAVE OCCURRED YOUNG
ATHLETES.
IN THESE SITUATIONS.
THAT MR IMAGINE THERE'S A
RESTROOM PORTERS AND ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AND ILLEGAL GRAY AREA
THAT WE WORK IN.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FOR THE CONCEPT OF
ATHLETIC TRAINING. FROM A NUMBER
OF OF STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE WILLINGNESS OF COMMITTEE
STAFF
OF TO ENGAGE ON LANGUAGE AND AND
OUR INTENT IS TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A STRONG.
BILL THAT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC
FROM UNQUALIFIED UNEDUCATED
PRACTITIONERS.
AND PROTECT ATHLETIC TRAINERS
AND EMPLOYERS FROM UNNECESSARY
LIABILITY.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LEILANI ACTING OUT
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ERIKA ROMERO BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING
THE PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFITS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JANET LOPEZ
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BOB MAILER
REPRESENTING STANFORD UNIVERSITY
SUPPORT.
A SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES AND
CALL UP THE. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES POLICE
.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS CARL
LONDON I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. HAS MAKE JUST A
COUPLE OF VERY BRIEF COMMENTS.
.
ABOUT THE BILL AND THEN ASK OUR
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN CHRIS READ.
TWO.
BRING THE BALL COURT TESTIMONY
CHRISS.
FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH IS AS BOTH
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER AND A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS WHICH WINNER
LETTER ONE WE BELIEVE IT
LICENSURE IS UNNECESSARY. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE.
PASS SCHEMES THAT WERE PASSED
IN PRIOR BILLS THEY GOT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK THAT INCLUDED
TOTAL PROTECTION.
AND.
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENT WOULD
BE. A OKAY FOR HANDLING ALL THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND DO WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT NOTHING IN THE
BILL DESPITE THE RHETORIC OF
SUPPORT. REALLY RELATES TO
ATHLETES.
ATHLETIC TRAINING OR SPORTS
DESPITE THOSE BEING THE
PRINCIPAL ARGUMENTS AND WITHOUT
ALTERNATE OVER TO CHRIS WHO.
AGAIN IS A BOTH AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER IN A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
AND CHAIR OF OUR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK CARL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE OPTIMISTIC
YOUR DAY. MY NAME IS CHRIS
FREEDOM GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE CHAIR. OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISCAL THEIR POSITION
ON THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AND SURVIVE
ATHLETIC TRAINER AND I RISE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE TEN.
THIS BILLS UNNECESSARY DOES
LITTLE TO TRULY PROTECT THERE'S
OF CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE RATHER TRAINERS
THERE IS OVERLY BROAD.
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
CONVENIENTLY USE THE ARGUMENT
THAT ATHLETES ARE SAFER WHEN A
CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINERS ON
THE SIDELINES.
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT A
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONAL THE
SIDELINES IS IMPORTANT TO THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
ATHLETES. HOWEVER THIS LANGUAGE
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ATHLETES
SPORTS SPORTS TEAMS OR SPORTS
VENUES.
INSTEAD IT CREATES A NEW
BATTERIES LEVELHEALTH CARE
PROVIDER WITH THE FREEDOM TO
WORK WITH ANY PERSON FOR NEARLY
ANY CONDITION WITH ESSENTIALLY
NO OVERSIGHT.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO PROVE PROVE THE
NECESSITY FOR LICENSURE THE
FUNDS OF AB THIRTY WHAT.
THIRTY ONE TEN HAVE CLAIMED THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST LICENSE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS SINKING TRAVEL TO OTHER
STATES FOR THEIR SPORTS TEAMS
LEGALLY. AND REVIEW OF THE FIFTY
OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT REGULAR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IT TURNS OUT
FORTY JURISDICTIONS HAVE LAWS
ALLOWING ATHLETIC TRAINER
CERTIFIED BY THE BOARD
CERTIFICATION AND TRAVELING WITH
ATHLETIC TEAM IN THAT STATE. TO
PRACTICE OUT THERE TRYING.
A CALIFORNIA BASED AUTHOR
TRAINER CONCURRENTLY LEGALLY
TRAVEL TO INFORM AUTHOR TRAIN
SERVICES IN ANY OF THE OTHER TEN
STATES BY OBTAINING A LICENSE
AND THAT STATE. JUST AS ANY
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
OBLIGATED TO.
IT SEEMS TO US THAT IT'S NOT THE
CALVIN LEGISLATORS JOB TO ENSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WORKING LEGALLY
IN ANOTHER STATE. RATHER TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND PROTECTION
OF CONSUMERS IN OUR STATE.
LETS LOOK AT THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMPONENTS OF THE
BILL.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN BECAUSE OUR
POSITION OVERSIGHT OF AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER THERE IS FAR
MORE LENIENT THAN THAT OF OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS. WHO HAVE
A GREATER LEVEL OF EDUCATION
TRAINING THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
NOTHING TRYING TO TREAT A
PATIENT FOR AN INJURY OR ILLNESS
FOR UNRESTRICTED AMOUNT OF TIME
WITHOUT THE PIGEON EVER HAVING
TO SEE A POSITION? AS LONG AS A
PHONE CALL BETWEEN THE AUTHOR
TRAINER IN A POSITION HAS
OCCURRED AT SOME POINT TIME.
THIS LEVEL POSITION OVERSIGHT IS
VASTLY MORE LENIENT IN ATHLETIC
TRAINING.
FOR ATHLETIC TRAINERS ABOUT HIS
LEVEL OF EDUCATION. THAN WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
AUTHORIZED VISITS ASSISTANCE OR
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST WITH A
MASTER'S DEGREE OR FOR A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST WITH A
DOCTOR'S DEGREE.
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL ALSO
ARGUE THAT THERE ARE BAD ACTORS
POSING AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE UNQUALIFIED.
AS DID EARLIER WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT HAVING A QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONAL ON THE SIDELINES IS
IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF OUR ATHLETES.
LICENSURE IS NOT ALWAYS THE
RIGHT WAY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
THOUGH.
PROVIDING PROTECTION OF THE
TITLE CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINER
BY ALLOWING ONLY THOSE
OBSERVATION FROM THE BOARD OF
CERTIFICATION FOR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS THE GOLD STANDARD AFTER
TRAIN PROFESSION. WOULD ENSURE
THAT ONLY THOSE WITH THE
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION TRAINING
OR HOLD THEMSELVES OUT AS OUT
THERE TRYING TO CALIFORNIA.
THIS ALONE IS A REASONABLE
SOLUTION THAT WAS RECOMMENDED BY
TWO THOUSAND FIVE CALIFORNIA.
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
REPORT ON ATHLETIC TRAINER
REGULATIONS ONE PASSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ON THREE
PRIOR OCCASIONS AND ONE
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION ON
EACH OF THOSE OCCASIONS.
FINALLY WE ARE CURIOUS WHAT IS
THE VOID THAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO RESOLVE.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SEVERAL
LICENSE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS NURSES NURSE
PRACTITIONERS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS WHO ARE AUTHORIZED BY
THE STATE TO BY THE TYPE OF CARE
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW ATHLETIC
TRAINERS TO FORM.
IN EVERY CASE THE OTHER TRAIN
HAS A LOWER EDUCATIONAL STANDARD
AND YET WOULD BE AUTHORIZED OF A
MUCH BROADER SCOPE UNDER THIS
BILL.
AB THIRTY ONE TEN IS A HIGHLY
FLAWED AND ON THE NECESSARY BILL
I STRONGLY URGE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO JOIN IN THE
OPPOSITION AND CAST A VOTE OF NO
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
A THE MORNING MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS IVAN ALL TOMORROW I REPRESENT
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE AMERICAN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION.
I WILL I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
MYSELF.
AND MY CLIENTS.
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY MIKE
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE PHYSICAL
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
AND.
LET ME JUST START BY SAYING THAT
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND AOTI A. ON HAVE
IN THE PAST WORKED WITH ATHLETIC
TRAINERS ON THIS ISSUE FOR THEM
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THEM IN THE
PAST ON.
ON.
TITLE PROTECTION AND
CERTIFICATION BILLS WE HAVE
WORKED WITH HIM IN THE PAST WHEN
THEY HAVE.
BROUGHT UP A SCOPE BILLS. BUT
AB THIRTY ONE TEN IS.
.
THIS YEAR'S VERSION AS WELL AS
LAST YEAR'S ARE BILL FIFTEEN OF
FIFTEEN TEN.
HAS PROVISIONS IN IT THAT ARE A.
PROBLEMATIC FOR OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY AND THAT IS THAT THEY.
THE ATHLETIC TRAINERS WOULD LIKE
TO PUT THEIR THEIR SELVES UNDER
THE BOARD CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
WE VIEW THIS AS A VERY
PROBLEMATIC WE HAVE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT EDUCATION TRAINING.
OF FIELD WORK REQUIREMENTS
WE HAVE DIFFERENT PATIENT
OUTCOMES.
WE DO NOT SEE A SYNERGY BETWEEN
ATHLETIC TRAINING AND
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
AND I QUITE FRANKLY LAST YEAR OF
THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT FEE
INCREASE THAT WAS IMPOSED ON ALL
ARM OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND LICENSED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR A UNDER THE GUISE THAT THE.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE
NEEDED JUST TO HANDLE THE
WORKLOAD OF THE OVERSIGHT OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THE THAT THE FOCUS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY. NEEDS TO
BE ON OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS.
WE THINK THAT THAT CERTAINLY IF
THE ATHLETIC TRAINERS A CONTINUE
TO SEEK A LICENSURE VERSUS A
TITLE PROTECTION CERTIFICATION
THAT THEY SHOULD.
THEY SHOULD PERHAPS HAVE THEIR
OWN BOARD PERHAPS.
BE UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
SINCE THEY REQUIRE A PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION IN THEIR OWN BILL.
BUT WE JUST DO NOT FEEL THAT
THE BOOK.
THEIR FEARS IS WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE ARM WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
WITH SCOPE AS WELL BUT I WON'T
REITERATE WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
SAID.
I WOULD JUST COMMENT ON ONE
ISSUE THAT WAS BROUGHT UP IN.
IN SUPPORT IN REGARDS TO.
THE NEED FOR HAVING ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AT HIGH SCHOOLS AND
SPORTING EVENTS
WE DON'T NECESSARILY DISAGREE
WITH THAT BUT THAT IS A
DIFFERENT.
ISSUE TO BE DISCUSSED THAT
ISN'T THAT. IS THE ISSUE OF
HAVING AN ATHLETIC TRAINER
AVAILABLE AT SPORTING EVENTS IS
A GOOD ISSUE TO TO HAVE. AS GOOD
DISCUSSION TO HAVE.
HOW DO WE PAY FOR IT HOW DO WE
MANDATE IT?
?
THAT IS A DIFFERENT DISCUSSION
THAT IS NOT PART OF THIS BILL
AND THAT'S ONE THAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY WILLING TO ENGAGE IN.
BUT NOT UNDER THAT NOT NOT IF
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE HERE THANK
YOU.
BATHHOUSES CAO THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY MPAS WE APOLOGIZE FOR
THE LATE OPPOSITION WHICH HAD A
WITH OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS
LATE LAST WEEK I'M TO DISCUSS
OUR CONCERNS RELATED TO THE
BROADNESS OF THE STATUTORY.
LANGUAGE AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT OF COURSE.
WHILE WE THINK OUR SUPPORT OF
ATHLETIC TRAINERS I'M HAVING A
PLACE IN THE TEAM AT THIS POINT
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THEY COULD.
TREAT OSEM ON A DAILY BASIS AS
AN EXAMPLE ARE OTHER CONDITIONS
THAT MIGHT BE BEYOND THEIR SCOPE
SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO TALK WITH
THE SPONSORS BUT AT THIS POINT
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIRTY ONE
TEN. THINKING.
PAT WHALEN ELLIS MOST NEVER SEE
HERE ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA UNION
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS WHO
REPRESENT ABOUT. THIRTY THOUSAND
NURSES AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AMONG THEM ARE
HUNDREDS OF PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS
AND OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS. I
TOO WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
AUTHOR FOR LATE OPPOSITION I'VE
REACHED OUT TO STAFF LATE
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
BUT WE ARE IN OF UP OPPOSITION
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS.
FOR ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
YES IS ONLY A COUPLE OF US RIGHT
AT THE MOMENT SO I GUESS I'LL
START.
.
YEAH THIS IS.
THIS HAS SOME HISTORY THIS BILL.
WHAT READING READING THAT BILL
ONE?
THE ANALYSIS OF. THAT AND I AM I
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S HERE BUT I
THINK REALLY THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ARGUMENTS THOSE A LOT
OF THE ARGUMENT GOOD ARGUMENTS
ON BOTH SIDES.
I THINK REALLY THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ISSUE THAT I SEE HERE
REALLY THIS.
SHOULD BE FLUSHED OUT IN BMP.
I THINK WHAT I'M GONNA. DO A
LOT OF RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
AND THIS YOU KNOW.
CHALLENGING SITUATION YEARS I'M
ONLY OFF THE BUILT THIS POINT
RESERVE JUDGMENT FOR THAT YOU
KNOW FOR THE FLOOR. TO SEE WHERE
THIS BILL GOES BUT I THINK
THERE'S SOME OBVIOUSLY SOME WORK
AND SOME LATE OPPOSITION THAT'S
COME IN THE DATA.
HE NOW HAS ME A LITTLE MORE
CONCERNED AS WELL ABOUT THIS
COUPLE ISSUES BUT.
AND RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
AUGUST AND I THINK I'LL JUST ON
A LEFT TO BUILD THIS PARTICULAR
POINT AND LET IT LET IT TO
PUBLIC AT THE BNP AND.
LET THEM FLUSH IT OUT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING.
ANY OF MISTER SCHER. THANK YOU A
PERSON WANTED WITH I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS SITE
BRAVERY PICKING UP THIS TOPIC.
BECAUSE AS I WAS JUST ALLUDED
TO THIS HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT
TOPIC MOVE THROUGH.
LAST YEAR WHEN THIS CAME
THROUGH COMMITTEE HAD MENTIONED
TO THE VAN AUTHOR THAT I HAD
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
IT WAS.
BEING CONSIDERED BUT I WAS
WILLING TO SUPPORT IT TO MOVE IT
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE THAT I SIT ON WITH YOU
AT BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
SO TODAY. ARE WILLING TO DO THE
SAME THING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL.
TO MOVE IT FOR BECAUSE I DO
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION BUT CERTAINLY ON
THE THE SCOPE ISSUES SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WERE. TO.
IN THE HEARING IF THERE'S GONNA
BE PROGRESS
WE'LL RESERVE FOR MY PERSPECTIVE
AT THAT POINT BUT BUT I DO THINK
A IT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH AND. HAVE
ALL OUR COLLEAGUES TICKET ON I
HAVE A LOT OF FUN FATE THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
THANK YOU WITH THE CHAIR.
JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS SINCE I
KNOW WE JUST SAW THIS BILL
BEFORE.
.
MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE OUR ANALYSIS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THE ONLY STATE THAT
DOES NOT REGULATE PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETIC TRAINING.
SO.
WATER THE OTHER STATES DOING I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE ALL
UNIQUE. IN THE WAY THEY LOOK AT
IT BUT.
WISE CALIFORNIA NOT AND. HOW DID
YOU KNOW? YOU LOOK THERE IS A A
BIT OF A PATCHWORK QUILT I'M
GONNA REFER TO DEFER TO MY AYE
EXPERT ON THAT CALIFORNIA IS
THOUGH WHEN OUT LIAR.
COMPARED TO THE OTHER FORTY NINE
IN NO REAL REGULATORY STRUCTURE
OF ANY.
KIND SO WE DO SET OURSELVES
APART.
WE DISTINGUISH OURSELVES. IN A
IN A NEGATIVE WAY AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED I'M GOING ALLOW MIKE'S
IS HARD TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
ABOUT SORT OF WHAT THAT NATIONAL
LANDSCAPE OUT LOOKS LIKE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF STATES ARE
LICENSURE. OVER FORTY I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER OF TOP OF
MY HEAD.
BY THINK IT'S FORTY THREE OR
FORTY FOUR THERE ARE SEVERAL
STATES THAT ARE. CALLED
REGISTRATION. OR CERTIFICATION
BUT HAVE THE UNDERPINNINGS OF
LICENSURE WITHOUT PROTECTION
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ABOARD AN
INVESTIGATION.
MINNESOTA HAS REGISTRATION
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS.
OF MOVING TOWARDS LICENSURE AND
THEY'VE PASSED THROUGH THE
SENATE AND AROUND. IN THE OTHER
HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
SO MOST STATES AGAIN ARE.
LICENSED OR SOMETHING THAT'S
AKIN TO LICENSURE.
DO YOU SEE THIS I MEAN AS A
FIRST STEP.
I MEAN.
EVENTUALLY YOU KNOW ONE WHO IS
BEING SAID IS THEY MEAN THEY
THEIR OWN OVERSIGHT THEY MAY
NEED. ARM TO DEAL WITH THEY DO
NEED TO DEAL WITH THE SCOPE
ISSUE.
I MEAN IS THIS.
THE FIRST STEP THAT. YOU SEE
WHEN THEY WOULD EVENTUALLY
EVOLVE INTO THAT.
WELL I DON'T WANT TO.
NARROW THE BILL ANYWAY AT THIS
POINT I THINK A MY COLLEAGUES I
HAVE INDICATED WE WILL BE
DELVING DEEP INTO THESE SCOPE
THAT DISCUSSIONS AT BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS.
BAH I A WELCOME A ROBUST A
CONVERSATION ON THAT ON HOW WE
CAN PROPERLY SET UP THE
STRUCTURE.
BUT.
AT THIS POINT.
THE THE BOARD OF OCCUPATIONAL.
THERAPY IS IS WELCOMING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE US THE
OVERSIGHT THE BOARD ITSELF. HOW
WE THINK?
AND AND THERE IS.
A I GUESS A BIT OF A A DOWNSIDE
IN THE LONG HISTORY ON THIS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO.
.
A RECORD OF NOT HAVING SUCCESS
IN GETTING IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK AND HAVING AND SIGNED THE
BENEFIT IS THERE HAVE BEEN.
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS AND
EXPLORATION OF THE FAILED
EFFORTS WE THINK WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST ARE AND THE AND THE
MOST.
THOUGHTFUL BILL OUGHT TO
PRESENT TO COMMITTEE TODAY WE
WILL AYE DEL FLY INTO OTHER
SCOPE AT ISSUES GOING FORWARD
AND THAT WE WILL CERTAINLY
ENTERTAIN THAT DISCUSSION I MOST
CERTAINLY WILL BE.
INTERESTED IN TALKING WITH ALL
OF THE.
INTERESTED PARTIES HONEST ON
THE BILL.
JUST THEM LESLIE YOU KNOW HAVING
BEEN AN ATHLETE ALL MY LIFE
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE.
MY SON YOU KNOWN FOOTBALL AND.
GOLF NINA VARIOUS SPORTS ON.
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER WHO MOVE YOU KNOW WHEN I
WAS. THANK GOD FOR TITLE NINE WE
HAD. YOU KNOW THAT OUR SPORTS
ABILITIES THEY WAS ATHLETIC
TRAINER.
.
SO YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE A
NURSE PRACTITIONER THERE
WOULDN'T HAVE A PHYSICIAN
WOULDN'T HAVE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE THERE ARE NONE ARE.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS
AT THE TIME AND. YOU KNOW THANK
GOODNESS FOOD THAT WHEN MY SON
HAD HIS CONCUSSION AND FOOTBALL
SO.
YOU KNOW I SEE THE THE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET THAT I I
THINK THE DISCUSSION IS
IMPORTANT SO.
MUM BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
WHAT BMP. DOES WITH IT THINKING.
BENEFITTED QUESTIONS BUT A
COMEDIC.
WHO HAVE A MOTION LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION?
NO EMOTIONAL HAVE THE SECOND.
ALRIGHT WE'RE DOLLARS MOTION AND
THE SECOND AND.
DO YOU OWN A CLOAK.
A MISTER CHAIR JUST ONE OF. THE
THINGS YOU FOR YOUR INVOLVEMENT
I IN THE CONVERSATION AND MY
COLLEAGUES.
.
ESPECIALLY MISTER CHIU SAID HE
HAS FAITH IN MAY ALSO TAKE YOUR
PRAYERS.
GOING FORWARD.
.
BUT HOPEFULLY THIS IS THE YEAR
THAT WE ACTUALLY A MOVE THIS
BILL FOR ONCE AND FOR ALL AND.
GET THAT SIGNATURE THE GOAL OF
COURSE IS BEING PROTECTION OF
THE PUBLIC.
FASHION ITSELF AND EMPLOYERS
ACROSS THE STATE. TO THE
COUNTRY'S MOST POPULOUS STATE
CAN FINALLY JOINED THE RANKS OF
ALL OF THE OTHER STATES THE
PROPERLY REGULATE ATHLETIC
TRAINING I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DO HAVE
THE SUPPORT. HIGH RECOMMENDATION
AMID DOWN SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU I'M SORRY.
I'M ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ONE ONE
ZERO MULLIN MOTION DE PASSED TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS KANSEN
CHU ARE. KANSEN CHU AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE ACOSTA.
I'M NOT VOTING.
ACOSTA NOT VOTING. DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
MEDINA.
IN THIS AREA ABSENT.
THE BILL IS ON HOLD WE HAVE
THREE VOTE SO WE WILL PUT IT.
ON A CALL.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISS MOON.
MOVING ON TO THE.
AB TWENTY TO TWENTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A. B.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY AND THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT. I MISTER SURE
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT
INTO THE MEASURE I WILL. BE
HAPPY TO TAKE THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON
PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU FOR THOSE.
AB TWENTY TO TWENTY WOULD EXPAND
ON THAT SIGNIFICANT STRIDES MADE
BY THE STUDENT ATHLETE BILL OF
RIGHTS TO PROTECT COLLEGE
ATHLETES UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
STUDENT ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS
ONLY. APPLIES TO INTERCOLLEGIATE
ATHLETIC PROGRAMS AT FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
THAT RECEIVE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
OR MORE IN ANNUAL REVENUE.
DERIVD FROM MEDIA RIGHTS FOR
INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS THIS
MEANS ONLY COLLEGE ATHLETES AT
UCLA YOU UC BERKELEY STANFORD
AND U. S. C. ARE PROTECTED UNDER
CURRENT LAW. THIS HAS CREATED A
TWO TIER SYSTEM IN OUR STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR COLLEGE
ATHLETES.
COLLEGE ATHLETES HAVE
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE STUDENT
ATHLETE BILL OF RIGHTS VERSUS
COLLEGE ATHLETES TO CONTINUE. TO
LEAVE IT ALL IN THE FIELD FOR
THEIR SCHOOL WITHOUT A
GUARANTEE.
THAT THEIR SCHOOL WOULD BE
WILLING TO DO THE SAME FOR THEM.
CURRENTLY FORTY THREE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS WITH COLLEGIATE ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS IN DIVISION ONE AND TO
HAVE THE AUTONOMY.
BUT AREN'T REQUIRED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER TO PAY FOR AN
ATHLETE'S MEDICAL EXPENSES IF
THE ATHLETE GETS INJURED
ADDITIONALLY COLLEGE ATHLETES
WHO GET INJURED DURING PRACTICE
OR GAME ARE NOT.
DETECTED FROM LOSING THEIR
ATHLETIC SCHOLARSHIPS AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY WILL REQUIRE
INSTITUTIONS TO PAY THAT DID
THAT DEDUCTIBLES FOR COLLEGE
ATHLETES WHO SUFFER SPORTS
RELATED INJURIES. AND FOR THE
COST OF ONGOING MEDICAL
TREATMENT FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS
AFTER A STUDENT HAS GRADUATED OR
LEFT THE UNIVERSITY FURTHER AB.
TWENTY TO TWENTY REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO PROVIDE AN EQUIVALENT
SCHOLARSHIP.
IF THE STUDENTS ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIP IS NOT RENEWED DUE.
TO AN INJURY WITH AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY WE CAN GIVE COLLEGE
ATHLETES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE
ABILITY TO SUCCEED BOTH IN THE
CLASSROOM AND ON THE FIELD WE
OUGHT NOT TURN OUR BACKS ON OUR
COLLEGE ATHLETES IN THE MOMENTS
WHEN THEY NEED US MOST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS REMOTE
JEHOVAH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL COLLEGE PLAYERS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU AGHA MORNING MY NAME
IS REMOTE HUMA A FORMER UCLA
FOOTBALL PLAYER. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF NTTA THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE PLAYERS ASSOCIATION.
THEN SHE PAYS AN ADVOCACY GROUP
MADE UP OF OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
CURRENT AND FORMER COLLEGE
ATHLETES FROM COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION.
THEN HE PAYS THE SPONSOR AB
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY CLASSES
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES.
A RECENT STUDY REVEALED THAT
SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES SUSTAIN A MAJOR COLLEGE
SPORTS INJURY.
AND FIFTY PERCENT OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES WILL SUFFER FROM
CHRONIC SPORTS INJURIES.
THESE ARE THE WHY SOME OF THE
HEALTHIEST PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
BUT PLAYING SPORTS FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES PUT IN
PERSON AT SIGNIFICANT RISK.
EACH OF THESE INJURIES COMES
WITH A CHOICE OF PAYING FOR THE
COST FOR MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
OR LIVING LIFE WITH A CHRONIC
INJURY.
IN ADDITION TO THE INHERENT
RISKS AND COLLEGE SPORTS BECAUSE
ATHLETES ARE TOO OFTEN PRESSURE
TO PLAY WITH SERIOUS INJURIES.
WHICH CAN INCREASE MEDICAL
EXPENSES.
SPORTS RELATED INJURIES HAVE A
DIRECT CAN HAVE A DIRECT
NEGATIVE IMPACT.
ON A PLAYER'S ABILITY TO
GRADUATE.
INJURIES REQUIRING A MAJOR
SURGERY AS WELL AS CONCUSSIONS
CAN DIRECTLY INTERFERE WITH THE
PLAYERS ABILITY TO ACHIEVE
ACADEMICALLY.
AND UNDER NCAA RULES COLLEGES
CAN REFUSE TO RENEW AN ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIP FOR PERMANENTLY
INJURED PLAYER.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT GRADUATION RATE
PROBLEM THEIR RANKS AMONG THE
WORST IN THE NATION.
EIGHTY ONE OF CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
CALIFORNIA'S COLORS TEAMS ACROSS
TWENTY NINE DIVISION ONE A
DIVISION TWO COLLEGES. HAVE
GRADUATION RATES BELOW SIXTY
PERCENT.
WITH AN AVERAGE GRADUATION RATE
OF FORTY FIVE PERCENT.
SOME OF THE COLLEGES HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW MUCH WOULD
COST EXTERNALITIES SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR TWO WEEKS FOR DEGREE
COMPLETION AND PAY FOR PLAYERS
MEDICAL EXPENSES.
BUT US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DATA. SHOW STRONG REVENUE AND
BOTH DIVISION ONE AND DIVISION
TWO.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
DIVISION TO REVENUE AMONG
COLLEGES AND CALIFORNIA INCREASE
FROM SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
TWO ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THIS IS A REVENUE INCREASE OF
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
NOTABLY PARTICIPATION ONLY
INCREASED FORTY SIX PERCENT.
WHICH SUGGESTS THE DIVISION TO
COLLEGES HAVE THE PATH THE MONEY
TO GUARANTEE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
PLAYERS. HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION ONE
COLLEGES ENJOYED REVENUE
INCREASE OF FOUR HUNDRED SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS DURING THE SAME
TIME PER.
WHILE PARTICIPATION NUMBERS
ACTUALLY DECREASED BY ELEVEN
PERCENT.
THESE COLLEGES CAN AFFORD TO
PROVIDE THESE PROTECTIONS.
THERE'S NO BETTER PLACE TO
DIRECT SOME OF HIS WHEN FOR
REVENUE.
THEN TO GRADUATE AND GUARANTEE
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR THE PLAYERS
WHOSE BODIES ARE BROKEN WHILE
GENERATING THIS MONEY FOR THE
COLLEGES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
XENON ANY OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FOR
.
GOOD MORNING ERICA ROMERO BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING THE
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS.
WHERE REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION?
FIRST WE ALWAYS FOLLOW YOUR XIN
ATHLETES AND TAKE THEIR HEALTH
AND SAFETY VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE
ENCOURAGE EVERY MEMBER TO COME
VISIT YOUR LOCAL COLLEGE CAMPUS.
AND VISIT ACROSS
THE DIVISIONS TO SEE HOW WE ARE
TREATING OUR STUDENTS AND THE
SUPPORT WE PROVIDE FOR THEM.
I AM UNFORTUNATELY FIRST I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
THE BILL MAKES REFERENCE TO THE
NC DOUBLE WAY. NOT NUMBER
INSTITUTIONS PLAY IN THE NC
DOUBLE A.
EFFECTS SIMILAR INSTITUTIONS
PLAY IN THE M. EIGHT I A. THE
SMALLEST OF THEM HAS A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S TOTAL.
BUT IT'S NOT OR SHOOT UP THE
POPULATION.
AND SO OF THIS BILL ACTUALLY
IMPOSES SEEM REQUIREMENTS ON THE
ANYWAY SCHOOLS THAN IT DOES ON
THE NC DOUBLE EIGHT SCHOOLS.
AND SO I.
WE TAKE ISSUE WITH IMPOSING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
INTENSELY CHOSE TO PLAN A
DIFFERENT WHICH.
SECONDLY.
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS RELATED TO.
THE MULTI YEAR SCHOLARSHIP
REQUIREMENT.
WHILE DIVISION ONE MAY CHOOSE
TO PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO THIS EXPERIENCE
THAT.
TWO INSTITUTIONS THAT DON'T HAVE
MEDIA REVENUE. THERE WAS A
REFERENCE MADE TO REVENUES
GENERATED BY SPORTS.
WE ALSO INSTITUTIONS FOR
REVENUES AND EXPENSES.
IN ONE CASE TICKET SALES WAS
TWENTY THOUSAND BUT INSTITUTIONS
BENDS OVER TWO MILLION.
EVERY OTHER PENDING WHAT'S
FUNDRAISE BY THE INSTITUTION.
THAT'S WHERE THE REVENUE CAME
FROM. ANSWER TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS INCREASES THE COST ON THE
INSTITUTION.
IT MEANS THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDRAISING HAS TO HAPPEN.
FOR.
ELIMINATION OF CERTAIN PROGRAMS
HAS TO HELP
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE TWO PROGRAMS
ESSENTIALLY THAT GENERATE
REVENUE IN THE TEND TO BE
FOOTBALL.
AND MEN'S BASKETBALL.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
INSTITUTIONS ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH THE FUND RAISING
FOR STERN ATHLETICS.
THIS IMPOSES ADDITIONAL COSTS ON
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND OBVIOUSLY
WE WANT TO PROTECT OUR XIN SO WE
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY. BUT WE DO
HAVE DIFFERENT DIVISIONS FOR A
REASON.
IT WERE TO BE REPLACED THERE'S A
COMMON MISCONCEPTION
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR SECTOR.
THAT WERE FLUSH WITH CASH IN
THAT WE CAN DO WHATEVER WE WANT
UNFORTUNATE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
CUSTOMER INSTITUTIONS ALREADY
HAVE UNMET FINANCIAL AID NEED.
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE YOU
AWARE OF THAT SO THERE THERE'S
NOT A MISPERCEPTION ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. ANIMAL
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION.
FOR THESE REASONS IN THE OTHER
CELL AND AN ART LETTER WHERE
POST.
GOOD MORNING EDGE MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE MINUTES
TAKEN OUR ARMED SUGGEST ME NOW
SO I DON'T KNOW THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN ADOPTED BY THE.
A RETIRED AUTHOR.
.
THE CSU HAS TWENTY CAMPUS IN THE
SYSTEM NINE OF THEM WERE
DIVISION ONE AND TWELVE OF THEM
WERE DIVISION TWO. AND ONE CAL
STATE MARITIME IS IN A AYE A.
DE LAST STRIKER IN THE SYSTEM
THAT DOES NOT HAVE ATHLETICS IS
CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS.
CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS IS OUR
NEWEST CAMPUS.
AND WAS THINKING ABOUT HAVING
ATHLETICS AT ONE POINT A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT OUT ACTUALLY HIRE
THE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR READY TO
GET GOING WITH THAT PROGRAM.
BUT THEY HAD THEY HAD FIRED AT
THE CHARACTER BECAUSE OF BUDGET
CUTS.
THAT WERE HITTING THE SYSTEM
SYSTEM I HAVE A STATE RACES
BASICALLY.
.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT AUDITOR'S ONE SCHOOLS.
.
IT ALL REDUCE INTO SCHOOLS THERE
ARE OPERATING OUR DIVISION TO
SCHOOLS ARE OPERATING ON A
STRING SHOESTRING BUDGET. FOR
EXAMPLE HUMBOLDT STATE CAME VERY
VERY CLOSE THEIR DIVISION TO.
THEY CAME VERY VERY CLOSE TO
CANCELING FOOTBALL LAST YEAR.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL FOR THAT
COMMUNITY FOOTBALL IS.
NOT REALLY A MONEY MAKER IT'S
PART THE COMMUNITY ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TOUCHSTONE FLAT COMMUNITY. THE
TRAVEL QUITE A BIT.
TO MEET THOSE DAVID CHIU
REQUIREMENTS POPULAR NOW THAT
THERE FRANKLY.
THE ARMED LESS CSU SCHOOLS THAT.
HAVE A BALL POINT PEN
EXIST NOW CRITIC DESPITE SISTER
SCHOOLS AFFABLE.
.
THIS IS GOING TO REALLY REALLY
MAKE CAMPUSES MAKE CHOICES ABOUT
HOW THEY SPEND THE MONEY THAT IS
TO SCHOOL LEVELS.
AND IT'S GOING TO MAKE THE HARD
CHOICES WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
BACK THE REPLACE SCHOLARSHIP
IT'S IN CONFLICT WITH OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS GOALS WHICH IS
TO GRADUATE STUDENTS A FASTER
RATE THAN WE CURRENTLY ARE AT.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRIVACY OF THE RIGHT OF ACTION
BECAUSE AND WHAT POTENTIAL COSTS
LIKE AN IMPACT ALL THE CAMPS WAS
WHILE. AND LOSERS WAS REPOSED.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU AYE TYLER AYE YOU ARE
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FOR SIMILAR SIMILAR
REASONS SIMILAR CONCERNS.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND A AYE CCU AYE WE ARE OPPOSED
WE DID IT NOT SUBMIT OFFICIAL
LETTER AND WE'RE NOT ON THE
ANALYSIS EITHER BUT JUST FOR THE
RECORD THAT IS OUR POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JANET LOPEZ REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO ONE ECHO THAT
COMMONSENSE YES YOU MAY HAVE
CONCERNS WITH A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION LANGUAGE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE POST THINKS IT
HERE.
GOOD MORNING.
BOB MAILER STANFORD UNIVERSITY
WE HAD SUBMITTED A A LETTER OF
CONCERNS OF THE STAFF O. GROUP
DILIGENTLY ON THIS BILL WE
APPRECIATE. ALL THE ATTENTION IT
GOT.
AND.
AS RESULT OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK DATA CONCLUDED TESTIMONY
MISTER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SHANE NONE.
.
MR VON HAVE WOULD YOU WANNA HEAR
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES AND.
YES THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THE THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS RAISED AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO CONSIDER.
.
ARGUMENTS IN AND PROPOSALS TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL. INTO
WHETHER WE.
A SCHOOL.
IS AN INTERPLAY OF ANY AYE A THE
ISSUE REMAINS THE SAME REGARDING
ATHLETES WHO'VE BEEN OFFERED A
SCHOLARSHIP IF IF THEY'VE BEEN
AND AND AND LET'S BE REALLY
CLEAR ABOUT THIS THESE AREN'T
ADDITIONAL COSTS.
THESE ARE COST EVER THEIR VERY
BIG COMMITTED TO A CERTAIN
STUDENT ATHLETE A SCHOLARSHIP
HAS BEEN OFFERED.
AND THEN THE PERSON GETS HURT
INCAPACITATED INJURY WE'RE JUST
SAYING YOU CAN FORGET ABOUT THAT
PERSON YOU CAN'T THROW MORE YOU
CAN TURN YOUR BACK ON THAT
PERSON LET'S KEEP A COMMITMENT.
THAT HELP THEM WITH THEIR
MEDICAL A COSTS THEY GOT HURT
PLAYING A SPORT THAT YOU GIVE
THEM A SCHOLARSHIP TO TO PLAY AT
YOUR SCHOOL. AND.
AND LET'S MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE SUPPORT THAT THROUGH THEIR
ACADEMIC.
.
EXPERIENCE AND ARE ABLE TO TO
GRADUATE SO.
REGARD THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION LOOK WHAT WERE OPEN TO.
ALTERNATIVE ENFORCING MECHANISMS
WE JUST THINK THERE SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IF SOMEONE'S BILL OF
RIGHTS
IS VIOLATED AYE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION ANOTHER THAT'S
RAISE SOME CONCERNS BUT.
BUT THAT THAT WAS THE MECHANISM
WE THOUGHT BEST AT THIS POINT IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO. ARM
AND FORCE THAT RIGHTS GIVEN
UNDER THIS BILL BUT WE WE ARE
OPEN TO. OTHER PROPOSALS.
.
YOU KNOW HER TO BROAD BASE
CONCERNED ABOUT CASA BY FRANK
THE I THINK THERE. WILL ALLOW A
LITTLE I'M EXAGGERATED THE THESE
ARE FOR INDIVIDUALS UNDER
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES WHOEVER
EVEN OFFERED A FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT AND THEN
INCAPACITATED I HEARD NO ONE
STATE ANY DATA. ABOUT HOW MANY
THAT IS AND HOW THAT BREAKS THE
BANK.
THE YOU KNOW FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR FUTURE. ARM BASED ON
A SCHOLARSHIP AND AND AND TO GO
TO A CERTAIN UNIVERSITY I THINK
WE SHOULD I'M KEEP OUR
COMMITMENTS TO THEM IT'S WORKED
SO FAR WITH THE STUDENT BILL OF
RIGHTS THAT WAS PASSED.
I'VE AT CERTAIN UNIVERSITIES I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE SHOULD BE
A SECOND TIER OF OF OUR COLLEGE
ATHLETES IN CALIFORNIA VISION OF
RECEIVE THE SAME. A SUPPORT OF
THE SAME RIGHTS WITHOUT I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER BONTA AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO.
TO THE SAP DO YOUR.
AMENDMENT FROM THIS COMEY. AND
OF DO HAVE THE.
YES RECORD BUT PASSED
RECOMMENDATION. AT THIS TIME THE
LIKE TO ASK US MADONNA SECRETARY
PLEASE.
BECAUSE OF.
SHOPPING. FARM SORRY WE DON'T
HAVE O'SHEA.
IT.
OKAY TO THERE IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
LOS VOTE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY. TWO.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY.
ASSEMBLYMAN BONTA DEEP THOUGHTS
AS AMENDED TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
KANSEN CHU.
KANSEN CHU AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO ACOSTA KNOW THE
CONSTANT NO DAVID CHIU. DAVID
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN. TREATMENT AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE.
THIS HEARING ABSENT.
I DO PASS.
RIGHT BILLS OF CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
OKAY WE HAVE WE HAVE.
OKAY CON WE WOULD DO HOUSE A
LOOK HE'S BEEN HERE ALL ALONG.
ALRIGHT WOULD DO AT ON HOW.
I'M.
AND ARMS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT KANSEN CHU.
HI WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED BY KANSEN TREAT CHIU. DE
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE TEN.
MULLIN.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE. MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE DEEP THOUGHTS.
TO BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
ALRIGHT.
INCLUDE A HUMAN TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH